the jurgen experience can you imagine if
there really are these creatures that
have no um
greed like if greed has been engineered
out of their body yeah they have no
materialism whatsoever no desire to own
things no desire to possess people all
reproduction is done through some sort
of technology
and they all they do is communicate with
thought so their thoughts are pure like
there's no misrepresenting it there's no
slick talk it's just pure thought and
you 100 get exactly what they're
thinking which forces everybody to kind
of be cool and they don't have any
emotions in that regard they're more
advanced they don't have any primate
thinking other than the ability to solve
problems yes and they come down and they
check on us every now and then check on
us yeah are we you know or like we're
like the
we're what they look like when they come
into time or something like right where
were the [ __ ] ancestors if you were
gonna go see uh a human ancestor
like at its most fascinating i would
want to be at the early early early days
i would want to see like australia
pithicus like what was that thing like
yeah what did it look like right like
how did it behave how did it move around
how many of them were there
how did they avoid getting eaten
right and just imagine that one day
that's going to be a person yeah that
makes skateboards i know it's so bizarre
bizarre and how quickly it can happen
bizarre yeah bizarre so strange yeah and
that we like apparently there were all
these like versions of proto hominins
it's not just neanderthals but like
denisovans implying like a war or some
kind of like survival of the fittest at
the very least yeah multiple versions of
humans yeah those denisovans they i mean
i don't think they even found out about
those until the 2000s
somewhere in the 2000s they realized
there was a whole nother version of the
human race that they weren't aware of
before do you remember that stupid movie
where like i can't remember the actor he
gets it's called iceman remember that
actor gets stuck in ice this is like 80s
they thaw him out like not an actor like
they wasn't he's talking about encino
man no not paulie's thing it was i think
i'm not sure which came first this one
was actually a romance i think what no
it's like a
like a a neanderthal or like someone
like that gets is in ice they thaw him
out
ice man
yeah what
he never saw this shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up
hey it's available on blu-ray
what what year did this take place i
i i honestly don't i saw it as a kid it
looks amazing 1984 that's amazing that's
before people knew any better
but i think it's like they fall in love
with women there's a romantic like i
think he's like there's a romantic
element do it oh my god but i could be
wrong about that how the [ __ ] does he
even learn english how long does that
take i'm watching it tonight absolutely
i find him
oh my god so he's encased in ice and oh
my god his heart's beating they bring
him back to life shut the [ __ ] up oh
they found an arrowhead in him yeah he
got shot with an arrow and then froze to
death and they have him and he wakes up
he wakes up this is the dumbest movie
i've ever even heard of
if this if he starts [ __ ] timothy
hutton's girlfriend this is like
this is prehistoric cuck porn
oh my god oh my god he's dressed like a
[ __ ] caveman this is how bad this
movie is look why is he wearing his old
clothes he didn't get any new clothes
they [ __ ] thought him out and put him
back in his old bear skins this is the
dumbest [ __ ] movie the world's ever
known
this is so stupid
and there's there's the girl oh yeah
she's like you don't even know him he's
like he's a [ __ ] caveman
he doesn't even understand fire
he is so sweet to me
and you are such a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
you're always busy at the lab
you're always busy at the [ __ ] lab
and ookay came and showed me his heart
and yeah he can't talk whatever
but you can't make love
got a [ __ ] stone knife to her throat
and she's [ __ ] like a rocket ship
you walk in
and she's she's actually grabbing the
stone knife and forcing onto her own
neck
oh my god dude that is so [ __ ]
that's just bad luck
you're like
bad luck you're in the arctic
you're in the arctic with like well
you're you're with the one of the only
women at the research station and she
starts [ __ ] a cave baby
oh my god
oh my god look he's hanging out look how
bad the makeup is who i come from oh
he's got whiskey
is that a bone oh it's a ball i thought
it was whiskey
i could be wrong about the romance i
can't remember play some of this
this dialogue so i can see how
ridiculous it must be
[Music]
and he just starts whittling his stick
carving a bone he's going to get mad
that dude keeps tapping on that log he's
going to [ __ ] him up
he put his poses scattered like bro you
are annoying yeah i'm ready to go to
sleep you're going to attract cats
that's what our nemesis was duncan cats
most of history most of history you know
i never thought of that before cats
that's why kids
this is rude this is a rude
[Laughter]
so movie it's the dumbest movie it's so
it's so dumb it's rude to me i mean
you're being rude to me you make me
watch this you made me watch no no no
not you whoever made it oh like if they
put that out there that you're making me
watch this oh yeah when i was a kid
though this was like gospel like i was
like i believed that this could happen
oh well it probably can
not right now but one day yeah imagine
if they found some [ __ ] remember that
one dude they found that had uh i think
he had an arrow stuck in his back
and he was uh
he had fallen into a crack in the
glacier or something like that he's been
completely frozen and then when the
glaciers were seeded they found him
and this guy had like tattoos it's like
yeah really interesting stuff yeah well
this is uh
you know
this is what my favorite
theory is like they're gonna do it to
one of the pharaohs to the mummy oh yeah
they're in but so they were right the
mummification process was because they
understood
that if you preserve your body long
enough one day they'll figure it out
they bring you back oh my god and then
you know right when they bring that
being back it like it starts controlling
things you know it just like gets back
to work could you imagine
they brought a pharaoh back to life and
he was like that dude from 300 yeah you
know super charismatic
xerxes he's like xerxes but also dr
manhattan yeah imagine we bring him back
and that's and he is the governor of ai
yeah and he just takes over from here